bonjour nous avons reçu beaucoup de
questions lors de notre journée spéciale
impôts le 31 mars voici quelques-unes de
ces questions et les réponses fournies
par les experts de la maîtrise en
fiscalité de l'université de sherbrooke
première question pour un étudiant qui
étudient dans une autre région que celle
où se trouve son adresse principale
est-ce qu'il a d'autres frais
déductibles à part les frais scolarité
réponse il y à un crédit d'impôt pour
frais de scolarité canada et québec il
n'existe pas de mesures spécifiques pour
un étudiant qui étudient dans une autre
région que son domicile mais si
l'étudiant doit déménager pour étudier
et que ce déménagement leur approche
d'au moins 40 km de son nouveau lieu
d'études il pourrait à certaines
conditions être admissibles à la
déduction pour frais de déménagement il
ya d'autres mesures possibles sur des
frais d'intérêts à payer sur un prêt
étudiant ou encore pour les nouveaux
diplômés qui travaille dans une région
ressource éloignés deuxième question
comment déclarer des transactions en
crypto monnaie réponse comme n'importe
quel autre transaction si vous gagnez un
revenu ou avait réalisé des gains payer
avec la crypto monnaie vous devrez les
ajouter à votre déclaration de revenus
lorsque vous effectuez une conversion de
crypto monnaie en monnaie courante vous
pourriez réaliser un gain ou une perte
en capital
advenant un gain la moitié de celui ci
sera imposable sous forme de gains en
capital et la moitié de la perte en
capital sera déductible s'il ya dieu
troisième question des collègues ont
reçu un avis de remboursement de 2000 $
de pcu versées en trop ce montant
faisait partie de nos revenus en 2020
comment allons-nous récupérer l'impôt
payé sur ce revenu réponse vous allez
recevoir un feuillet le t4 à et un feu
hier l un pour les résidents du québec
où le montant de votre remboursement sur
un indiqué ce feuillet vous permettra de
récupérer votre impôt payé en 2020 en
déduisant le montant de remboursement
lors de la production de votre
déclaration de revenus vous pouvez
demander la déduction sur 2020 et donc
corriger vos déclarations passées où
vous pouvez également demander la
déduction sur votre déclaration 2022
quatrième question peut-on réduire le
coût pour faire un rapport d'impôt comme
le prix du logiciel de turbo impôts
réponse si vous êtes un salarié vous ne
pouvez pas déduire le coût afin de
produire votre déclaration de revenus
parce qu'il s'agit d'une dépense
personnelle si vous êtes un travailleur
autonome ou si vous possédez un immeuble
locatif pour lequel vous avez gagné du
revenu de location il vous sera possible
de déduire le coût en fonction d'un
pourcentage des revenus cinquième
question allons-nous bénéficié cette
année d'un report pour payer un solde dû
cette année la date limite pour produire
les déclarations de revenus et le 2 mai
2022 les délais ne sont pas reportées et
les gouvernements n'ont fait aucune
annonce à ce sujet plus de réponses
encore sur radio canada.ca barres
obliques impôts 2022